Imma tell you something.
Every person in their life
has had a million-dollar idea.
No doubt.
It's just, are you
going to take action?
You definitely do not need
to go to business school
to become an entrepreneur.
I started Spanx as a
frustrated consumer.
I had $5,000 set
aside in savings.
I simply wanted to be able to
wear white pants to a party
and have nothing
show underneath it.
The entire time, everyone
told me no and said,
this is not a great idea.
But let me tell you one thing.
That means you've come up
with something brand new.
Take it as a compliment.
This MasterClass
class is for anyone
out there who's in search
of an idea, has an idea
and doesn't know
what to do next,
is wanting to start a
business, or has already
started a business.
I guess, in some
way, I'm saying,
I think this class
is for everybody.
Before I started
Spanx, I actually
was selling fax
machines door to door.
I got kicked out of
building after building.
And one day, I thought,
I'm in the wrong movie.
Like call the producer,
call the director.
This is not my life.
What happened?
I can tell you the things that
I focused on very early on.
Three things-- make it,
sell it, build awareness.
People are looking for that,
I want to be a $100 million
company in the
first year and I'm
going to raise as much
money as I possibly can.
And just check in
with yourself on that,
and be willing to start small.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Why are you doing this?
What's the why?
And who are you in the world?
Share that part of the story.
I mean, the more vulnerable
you're willing to be,
the deeper the connection
will be with your consumers.
I hope that you're tuning
in, and you're seeing me,
and I become the
example that you needed
to say, check, yes you can.
I'm Sara Blakely, and
this is my MasterClass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]